with reaction our two esteemed attorneys
scott Bolden joins us from Las Vegas
along with Alan Dershowitz in New York
he's the author of the new book
trumped-up how the criminalization of
political differences in dangers
democracy great to see both of you
professor Dershowitz judge Ellis you
know him well I know him well for a long
time ago when I was a litigator he's an
incredibly talented judge he pretty much
calls balls and strikes 77 years old
senior judge on the Eastern District he
just laid into the special counsel's
office
he's cantankerous he's known for that
too but he laid into them there was a
one quote that I especially want to
raise here he said I don't see what
relationship this indictment has against
man afford with anything the special
counsel is authorized to investigate
it's unlikely you're going to persuade
me the special counsel has this
unfettered power to do whatever he wants
look every criminal lawyer I know every
experienced lawyer has known from the
beginning what's going on they're going
after people like manna Ford and Flynn
and Cohen not because they have any
interest in any of them they just want
to flip them they want to make them not
only sing but as the judge put it in his
statement maybe even make them compose
you know I think I came up with that
phrase composing instead of singing the
judge was just saying what we all have
known right from the beginning the only
difference between this judge and other
judges is this judge is completely and
totally honest he calls it the way he
sees it he's absolutely right this is
what's been going on the amazing thing
is that he called him on it and he said
to prosecutors essentially you can't do
that if you're a special counsel you
have to go after directly the evidence
that's within your mandate you can't be
finding people creating or exaggerating
or coming up with crimes not in order to
get those people but in order to squeeze
them and get them to sing and compose
it's about time a judge honestly looked
at the situation and assessed that you
and I have been talking about this now
for months
we shouldn't be surprised but it's
surprising that and refreshing that a
federal judge will say that it also have
indicates what another point I made why
didn't Muller take this case out of
Virginia and try to put it in Washington
DC because he knows the
he would get more positive judges more
positive jurors in the District of
Columbia then he would get in Virginia
in Virginia he's going to get judges
like this who was straight in DC he's
going to be statuary
who a much much more anti-trump and so
clearly that was judge shopping jury
shopping when I said that I was called a
racist I was condemned congressmen
condemn me professors condemn me but I
think I think this opinion vindicates
what I've been saying for a long long
time Scott he has we do have another
aspect of the case that's still in DC I
think we might have just lost got there
that is in DC and we'll get him back let
me know and it's Amy Berman Jackson
professor Dershowitz who is a Obama
appointee and so she is she still hasn't
ruled on the motion to dismiss but these
bank banking transactions go back to
2004 in 2007 and so Dreeben tries to
argue today saying well no this is
within the scope of the investigation
and he and he said I'll be the judge of
that he's like I don't think so I'll be
the judge of that so a 2004 2007 an
investigation that began in 2014 a
professor was somehow just just looped
into the Muller investigation it is
ridiculous it's so patently obvious from
the very beginning you were way ahead of
the curve on it well no and it's so
important because what they're doing to
these people like Manta for Dan Flynn
and Cohen could happen to any of us if
we happen to be collateral damage if you
know somebody who they're going after
they're gonna find something on you
they're gonna squeeze you this is
something that has plagued the American
justice system for many decades look if
they do it to get the Mafia maybe it's
understandable if they do it to get
terrorists maybe it's understandable but
to do it to get an elected President of
the United States somebody who I voted
against but who's the elected President
of the United States to use that tactic
the Mafia terrorist tactic of squeezing
people and making them testify and
making them sing and making them
composed in dangers the civil liberties
of all Americans let's look at what
President Trump said today after he
heard about the continuing conversation
about whether he should speak to a grand
be interviewed by Muller he made these
comments I would love to speak I would
love to go nothing I want to do more
because we did nothing wrong I have to
find that we're going to be treated
fairly because everybody sees it now and
it is a cure which none if I thought it
was there I would override my lawyers
you know it's so important everybody
should read my article in today's USA
today because I give advice to the
president I never give it to him
directly but I give it to him through
the media it would be a terrible mistake
for him to voluntarily testify unless he
has no choice no prosecutor has ever
tried to get somebody to speak to him in
order to help that person you have the
person speak to you in order to spring a
perjury trap or have them fill gaps and
I have never in fifty years of practice
had one of my clients speak to a
prosecutor or voluntarily appear in
front of a grand jury he may have - they
may subpoena him but then he has legal
resources he can fight the subpoena on
the grounds that this judge has now
apparently ruled saying that many of the
questions are beyond the scope of the
mandate of the special counsel others
are within the privilege of a president
not to have to respond an answer why he
pardoned why he fired why he did this
why he did that those are not
appropriate question so I think there
are challenges the president can level
at a subpoena but the one thing he
shouldn't do is volunteer to sit down
and talk through a process that comes of
that no it's a I don't care how people
think they're so smart and Alan you and
I have been around this with witnesses
of the more prominent the witness the
more problems in a deposition because
they don't want to hear your advice they
don't want to be coached they don't want
to do MOOC courting they want to go and
I can handle it
look at Bill Clinton look at Bill
Clinton he got impeached because his
lawyer gave him the advice to go and
testify about his sex life at a
deposition and he could have settled the
case and not testified but he didn't do
that to you this in that case he took
the advice as a lawyer he didn't take
the advice I gave him on Geraldo on this
network not to testify but he you know
he he made the mistake and I I don't
think that President Trump is going to
make the mistake of testifying unless he
can do it in a controlled setting a few
hours with his lawyer president limited
questions about limited subjects perhaps
written answers you know if I were the
president's lawyer I take advantage of
these 40-something questions and I'd
respond to them in writing and say to
the American public see I'm not afraid
to answer these questions the only
reason they want to now talk to me in
person is they want to spring a perjury
trap and there's no justification for
using the grants it's great it would be
lunacy Scott Bolden we promise it was
not a conspiracy to take down your sex
life I promise I love having you on
you're one of my favs your reaction to
what's happened today we can go back to
the to the district court judge in the
Eastern District of Virginia or you can
hit any of the issues we've been talking
about well I've been I'm chomping at the
bit in regard to judge Ellis having
appeared before him a handful of times
in the last 5-10 years I'm not surprised
that Judge Ellison's comments and he was
equally hard on not only Muller but also
equally hard on mana for its lawyer and
his legal team in regard to their head
shaking and what-have-you but he is he
is a smart judge I don't disagree with
professor Dershowitz in regard to how
the process works but they shakedown
drug dealers they shakedown Street
criminals and what-have-you and so but
remember one thing the judge didn't
order the judge didn't dismiss the
indictment he wants to see the whole
memo because he may not trust Muller but
he didn't render a decision and so a lot
of judges will press both sides and then
in the end rule in favor of one that
just based on the questioning you may
think that it's not that he's leaning
one way but go the other way so you got
to keep that in mind he did not issue an
order secondly the hearing today was in
my opinion was really more about whether
Muller okay did he have does he have
jurisdiction or not but then the other
thing to notice is they got local
counsel they're from the Eastern
District yeah and I think if anything
judge Ellis is gonna rule if he goes
this far to say you could prosecute
Manta Ford if you want but you got to do
it out of the Eastern District and
prosecutors always do forum shopping not
profession there she was absolutely
right nobody wants to try a case in
front of a decent juror because they
tend to be more liberal so they do reach
out to Virginia if they can make the
in regards to the the rest of the issues
I'll tell you the subpoenas and and and
what the house investigators are doing
I'll be honest with you
they really ought to just let the Muller
investigation go forward this whole
corruption piece and and picking and
choosing it heaven forbid we have
Congress hold the executive branch
accountable or they're you know the
judge I mean they also keep each other
honest but going investigation you don't
have to pick one investigations ongoing
investigation is a travesty of justice
yes we do want them to have an ongoing
oversight responsibility and that don't
be timers of that at the conclusion you
don't want to do engagement yeah all
right guys we're out of time thank